♪♪
Cherry:
I'm 23 years old.
♪♪
Cherry:
And I still don't understand
what it is that people do.
What?
Just thinking that you're shady.
♪♪
(Gun shot)
It's a very epic film.
Antony Russo:
It spans 18 years of Cherry's
life.
And it's ultimately a modern
tragic love story.
Cherry:
I take all the beautiful things
to heart.
Cherry:
Until I about die from it.
(Glass shattering)
Tom Holland: It's kind of
a role of a lifetime.
Tom Holland:
This character explores so many
different avenues of life.
Ciara Bravo:
You have a romantic film, that
leads
into a war film,
Ciara Bravo:
that leads to a drug film.
Cherry:
Sometimes I feel like I've
already seen everything that's gonna happen.
♪♪
Cherry:
And it's a nightmare.
We have a very passionate
connection to our hometown of
Cleveland.
Joe Russo:
And the locations of the book
were specific
to areas that Anth and I grew up
in.
♪♪
Joe Russo:
We had very similar upbringings
with extremely different
outcomes.
The City is really a character.
So what makes a joker like you
wanna join the United States
Army for?
Sense of purpose.
(Thud)
(Explosions) (Automatic gunfire)
We wanted to try to convey as
best as we could,
Anthony Russo:
the experience of being in Iraq.
With Joe and Anthony, they're
constantly pushing to go the
extra mile.
Joe Russo:
We made a decision to sit in
longer takes with him.
Joe Russo:
Sitting with someone who is ill
prepared for death and destruction
Joe Russo:
on a scale, uh, that he's never
seen before.
(Explosions)
♪♪
There's so many moving parts.
Tom Holland:
We're so lucky, we've got the
crew to be able to put moving parts
Tom Holland:
in the right place.
Newton Sigel:
Prepping this movie, we talked
about it as Jazz.
there's a huge process of
discovery.
We're always trying to find the
magic with any scene that really
brings the story out.
(Gunshot)
Working with the Russo brothers,
has been one of the best
experiences of my life.
Everything about this film. The
stars have just aligned and it's
just been such a wonderful time.
Tom Holland:
And a lot of that is down to the
way
Tom Holland:
the Russo's hold themselves on
set.
We love this idea of sharing
the experience with everyone
Joe Russo:
and this entire group produced
something I think that we're all very proud of.
♪♪